Matteas: My name's Drov Matteas
from Disney/ABC
Television Group.
We were approached
by Google O3D team
to...
to develop kind of
an interactive 3-D experience
in the browser.
We also have
a developer initiative
where we're aiming
to expose certain metadata
from our company
to empower developers
to create experiences
around our content.
And it seemed
like a perfect fit
of new technology,
and our APIs
kind of develop
an exciting application
that fits right in the middle
between that, so...
man: So can you talk a little
bit more about
how you came to the technical
decision to use--
working it and integrating it
into your application?
Matteas: Um, yeah, I mean,
the ideation
of the application came
from kind of the inspiration
of O3D and doing
hardware-accelerated graphics
in the browser.
I mean, previous, we would
consider doing the application
in Flash, but when we saw
the demos of the performance
of O3D running in the browser,
we thought it was cool
and just wanted to--
kind of experimented.
I mean, my team, we're all kind
of fun tech guys ourselves
and wanted to kind of experiment
ourselves,
so it was kind of a cool thing
to do.
We needed, you know,
we needed something fun
to kind of showcase
our developer initiatives,
so it just worked out.
man: So, as developers,
we really value people
who are able to share
war stories and lessons
from a technical counter,
especially as O3D is
kind of new.
It'd be great to get feedback,
and if you could tell everyone
what you think one particularly
difficult period of development
was that you faced
and how you approach
the technical counter.
Matteas: Um, yeah, so the most
difficulty for our team
was we have no previous
experience with anything 3D.
But what we do have is a lot
of experience with JavaScript.
So probably for us
was the initial learning curve
of how to create the models
and animate them
in 3D.
But it was actually fairly--
I mean, the whole application
was built in four to five weeks,
so it was fairly kind of rabid
to get to a perfect stage
where we could start
playing around
and using kind of the demos
that Google provided.
You know, it really,
really helped us out.
man: Great.
Matteas: Yeah.
man: And, so I mean,
how long does--
what do you see
as the next steps
for your application?
Matteas: I'd love--I mean,
as we add more functionality
to our API, I mean,
I would just love to add that--
I mean, to basically add that
to the front end as well.
You know, I think, through
the process of this project,
we found
a really interesting way
to use 3-D to navigate
through video content
and through imagery
of our video content.
So it's kind of the first steps,
at least internally,
for how we can create
a new interface
for our video content
using 3-D.
I mean, prior to this, our
websites have been very static.
Or maybe dynamic
in a 2D fashion,
but adding kind
of the third dimension allows us
to provide more information
intuitively to the user.
So I'd like to--I mean,
over the case of the summer,
really kind of
blow out the functionality
of this application
and maybe apply it
to more of a mainstream user
base than just the developers
on our site.
man: So given what you've
learned, working with O3D,
um, maybe getting some
of the feedback [indistinct]
is there anything that
you're going to change
based on the feedback?
Matteas: So, based
on the feedback
we got from the developers
in Sandbox, if there's anything
we would--
man: Based on the experience
of things
that you might do differently
for any visualizations--
Matteas: With application,
or with O3D--
Just in general, I guess.
man: Yeah, just in general.
Matteas: Yeah, I mean, we had
a lot of feedback.
I mean, in regards
to O3D,
most of the feedback was
how fast we got to the point
we got to, and, you know,
although we didn't have
that prior 3D experience,
it was actually kind of fun
to get to the point
where we are
in a very short period of time.
Most of the feedback
we got
in regards to our application
was around larger amounts
of data being presented.
Right now, our application shows
a limited set
of maybe eight or ten results.
So really kind of the problem
that we're gonna now go back to
is how do we expand that
to--I don't know--
maybe hundreds of results,
right,
which we potentially have
in our database,
so it'd be interesting
to kind of play
with that interaction model.
Yeah.
Cool.
man: What's the most interesting
comment--or feedback--
that you've gotten?
Matteas: Probably somebody--
some of the visual search
techniques we're doing
with the video, people are,
"Does ABC really know
that you're doing that?"
You know, a lot of people
can't believe that,
as ABC traditionally being so
protective of their content,
that we're embracing developers
as we are.
Or at least attempting to,
at least, now.
So that was kind of funny.
But it's very exciting to see
kind of developers--
you can see them kind of come up
with their ideas
and really look forward
to working with stuff
that we're doing, so...
It's cool.
man: That sounds really great.
Matteas: Yeah.
man: Great.
Matteas: All right.